We learned yesterday that Jared Kushner and
Ivanka Trump earned somewhere between one
hundred and seventy two million dollars and
six hundred and forty million dollars in what
is called outside income while working in
the White House during the presidency of Donald
Trump.
This was a financial analysis done by crew
Citizens for Responsibility and Ethics in
Washington.
I forget exactly what Cruz stands for.
They looked at financial disclosures and you
might remember that Donald Trump famously
said he would donate his salary and Jared
Kushner would be an unpaid adviser to Trump
and Ivanka would be an unpaid adviser.
You know, none of them were taking salaries
while working for the government.
And that was supposed to prove there's no
nepotism and there's no concerns or whatever.
And of course, they continue to make massive
amounts of money from their steaks.
For example, Ivanka Trump stake in Trump's
hotel in D.C., which was frequented and patronized
by world leaders and diplomats in order to
ingratiate themselves with Donald Trump.
We saw all sorts of Ivanka businesses, including
related to I think it was handbags and whatever
else, even sometimes promoted on national
television by paid adviser to Trump, Kellyanne
Conway.
We saw all of it, and they made an insane
amount of money while working in the White
House advising a sitting president.
But but.
But but what about Hunter Biden?
Right.
I thought that was the issue.
Imagine making as much as two thirds of a
billion dollars over four years while working
a government job at the highest level.
Now, in reality, families should simply be
banned from serving in any position whatsoever
for the federal government.
When a family member is president, at minimum,
no matter what you're doing, you should have
to be Senate confirmed.
Now, this is, of course, in addition to the
fact that they cost the American people and
taxpayers way more money, Ivanka and Jared,
through their constant trips, Secret Service
protection and the whole thing.
So, yeah, it's truly shocking.
You might remember and we're already seeing
a lot of responses about this, people saying,
well, look, the Clintons became super wealthy
after Bill Clinton was president.
Barack Obama became super wealthy after he
was president.
Yes, that's after after they weren't making
millions and hundreds of millions of dollars
during their White House years.
And, you know, this is a reality.
Yeah, Bernie's a millionaire.
He's also almost 80.
And at this point, if you've been making six
figures for 30 years, unless you're really
bad with money, you would be a millionaire.
Presidents end up making a lot of money because
people hire them for speeches after they're
out of office, they get a cushy book deal.
But this isn't even the president.
This is the president's kids while working
at the White House, making somewhere between
one hundred and seventy two million and six
hundred and forty million dollars.
So you can't really.
What about your way out of that one?
Now, meanwhile, we don't really know what
the future is of many of these Trump businesses.
A lot of the Trump real estate holdings losing
value over the last four years.
Half the country, close to half the country,
won't even go to Trump hotels anymore for
political reasons.
And we know the D.C. hotel is struggling and
a lot of these others are struggling.
That is all true.
But it doesn't mean that these four years
weren't extremely profitable for this family.
And so when Trump said he would drain the
swamp, he obviously didn't do it.
But the personal incomes of these individuals
while he was in office are absolutely and
completely stunning.
So they're all going to be fine.
You know, some people.
Feeling bad that Jared and Ivanka aren't welcome
back in the social circles in Manhattan where
they previously were, regulars don't feel
bad for them.
They're going to be fine.
They were able to work high profile government
jobs.
I know they didn't have a salary.
I know continue making hundreds of millions
of dollars and they are going to do just fine.
And they did much of it on the backs of taxpayer
dollars.
That's the reality.
We will take a quick break at the Trump impeachment
trial.
Number two starts today.
We'll be covering it live.
I have FOX clips coming up.
I have voicemails coming up and so many more
things.
Glad you're with me today.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.